bonjour et bienvenue au fitness park je
me présente monsieur sur à wilfrid
cogérant des finesses parc de l'île de
la réunion
donc nous avons pour le moment trois
fitness park 1 qui se trouve sur saint
pierre un deuxième donc ici à saint
denis et en 3e à sainte marie avec en
projet d'ouverture en fin d'année sur
l'ouest au niveau du port la possession
nous avons actuellement deux agents
commerciaux
deux agents d'entretien et aussi deux
agents polyvalents le concept fitness
park et sur trois choses sur les
horaires 6 heures 23 heures 7 jours sur
7 le prix
moins d'un euro par jour mais aussi du
matériel haut de gamme à votre
disposition
alors nous recherchons actuellement en
fait des agents commerciaux pour nos
différences entre donc les profils
recherchés sont en fait varier puisque
nous avons pas forcément un profil qui
ne correspondent mais plusieurs ce qu'on
recherche actuellement en fait c'est
plutôt des valeurs humaines et le
travail c'est à dire être rigoureux
travailleur être empathique avoir
vraiment le sens du contact voilà c'est
une qualité fondamentaux pour
recherchons actuellement chez fitness
park puisque le relationnel que nous
pouvons développer avec nos clients est
très important pour nous mêmes mais
aussi pour l'image de notre société
donc si vous avez l'une ou l'autre de
ces qualités et boulet de venir dans un
club dynamique mais en fait vous avez
aussi la possibilité d'apprendre des
choses et aussi de d'évoluer dans notre
groupe vous êtes les bienvenus voilà ce
que nous recherchons exactement qu'ils
aient des diplômes ou pas peu importe
c'est vraiment en fait le fait de tous
les jours en vouloir apprendre davantage
et faire des gestes roland demande